everybody what's going on welcome to the
17th video for our particular Python
programming massive program tutorial I
love how I call it something different
every time in this video what we're
going to do is we're going to talk about
the adding middle indicator function so
we've done the top and the bottom I'll
just say again this isn't the best way
to do it a lot of these these two
functions are identical to each other
and we're about to add another pretty
sloppy function I do intend to clean
these up but we're gonna do that in time
I'm gonna go ahead and add this middle
indicator function and just acknowledge
that I realize it is not the cleanest
but that's okay
so copy paste and instead of top
indicator we're gonna call this middle
indicator and instead of globalink top
indicator we're in a global middle
indicator also if you didn't catch what
I just did I wasn't really explaining it
but the beginning of this indicator
function is on is pretty is identical to
the other ones so I just copied this
like I just copied that part of that top
indicator and pasted it there so so
that's good enough there now we're gonna
go ahead and come down and so if data
paste is tick now we just we're not
gonna do it but otherwise we're gonna
get started so now we're gonna say if
what does not equal none then we're
going to actually perform some stuff
here the next question is if middle
middle indicator equals none so first
question is if if the choice was not
none the second question is is the
middle indicator currently none so it
pops hello so if that's the case what
we're gonna do is we're gonna ask now if
yeah if what equals SMA so if the user
said hey I want to do a simple moving
out
what do we want to do and so here we're
gonna do mid IQ and that's going to be
equal to TK TK as usual so we're gonna
have this like basically window pop up
like we did pretty much right here so in
fact we could really copy and paste but
I guess we'll right through it just
because some people might not have
followed how that exactly is working so
we'll write it one more time so mid I Q
equals TK TK then we are going to set
that little window title so this is like
a you know its own little window submit
IQ loops dot WM title will be periods as
before the next thing we're gonna do
label equals T TKD TKD Abel capital L to
mid IQ text equals top choose how many
periods you want your SMA to be period
easy enough now label dot pack as usual
we're going to pack this to the side
equals top and then fill 2x and Patty 10
now e equals ttk entry that's gonna go
to the mid IQ that we're making right
now
eita insert and this is again where we
make basically a default value we're
gonna choose 10 for the default value e
dot pack and an e dot focus underscore
set and now we're going to define
callback and the callback is good
basically do exactly what the other
callback did to them for the most part
it's gonna global middle indicators it's
gonna global dat counter and then we're
gonna do middle indicators equals an
empty list and that is why we
if middle indicator equals none because
at this point we're saying middle
indicators is an empty list at this
point so yeah and then we're gonna say
periods equals e dot get group is
nothing at the moment group dot append
they chose SMA so we'll append SMA and
then group dot append and here we're
gonna append the int value of periods we
didn't do that below
and we'll see if we get away with that I
believe I pulled that from the main
application so I think we do but we
shouldn't anyway we dumped out of hand
int periods and then we'll do middle
indicators dot append the group and now
we'll say dots counter equals 9000 and
then print middle in the cater set to
comma middle indicators and then mid IQ
dot destroy okay so basically this is
all of the code that we just put out and
so what's happening make the window how
many periods basically the NR a default
that and a second will run the callback
when that's done it sets the middle
indicator to SMA and the value and then
it destroys the window subsequently we
need to add the button so we're gonna
say B equals T TK button dot and then
mid IQ so mid indicator question if
you're confused about IQ we're gonna say
text equals submit and width equals ten
and command equals callback and now
basically all this remains
if the user picks EMA for exponential
moving average so we're gonna copy all
of that and we're gonna come down here
paste and instead of SMA EMA and your
EMA let's capitalize that coming on down
buh buh buh bah blah middle indicators
no problem grouped out a pen EMA easy ZZ
ZZ boom done so that's it now we need to
ask the question basically we need to
come back and if what if there's already
a middle indicator so chances are a lot
of times when people add simple moving
averages they generally add to at least
but generally - and they look for
crossovers of those two simple moving
averages or exponential moving averages
whatever so now we need to answer the
question L if there is something in that
middle indicator or else really it's the
only other thing so that was if since
we're we're kind of like that was a long
bit of text so we're gonna go ahead and
measure that would be two tabs I believe
over so tab tab okay so we'll come down
here tab tab else so in this scenario
basically we're asking if if there is
already indicators there else if what
equals SMA basically we're gonna come
let's let's go ahead and copy and paste
this entire thing here and the only
thing that really changes is we just
don't define middle indicators as an
empty list okay so which I'm pretty sure
that's the only thing we're gonna go
ahead and just copy and paste this and
this is why I meant like this is really
messy not ideal but so if what equals
SMA delete the second version then we
still ask the question all of that we're
gonna do everything there and the only
thing we're gonna leave out basically is
defining middle indicators as an empty
list so
first of all probably the best thing to
do actually would have been to not use
text none for middle indicators and then
we always append two middle indicators
so that'll probably be how we're gonna
clean up this function but this is how I
have the code right now so we'll just do
that and then basically we do the exact
same thing for EMA so we'll just copy
paste so that was this here so am a
capital e whoops capital e there EMA
middle indicator set to that and that's
yeah okay so we've got all that and now
we just need one final statement here
that's basically one tab over else
middle indicators equals none make empty
lists
we'll probably do that to optimize this
because this is really messy but else
basically means they have none okay so
with all that code we should be all set
let's run and see how many syntax errors
we have no syntax errors wow what a
surprise
okay middle indicator SMA boom err
really couldn't get away from it
alright so what do we got Wow this was
not what I wanted to see let's see
return
I'm definitely not immediately seeing
what my problem is it's obviously
something in this change middle
indicator function which is strange that
it's like referencing I've never seen
something like reference back that far
usually the trace back doesn't go that
far back and so that's what's really
confusing me so some are all these lines
we have what appears to be maybe a
parent issue but it's happening
basically at this point and maybe it's
not really sure who the parent is here
TK Dottie I think I might see my issue
hold on right okay so right so we're
saying that's a lot of that it's that
we're gonna have to make so I should I
think I found at the inche issue here so
we're doing TK dot TK but that's
actually we need to you know fully put
the parameters there's otherwise it's
referencing basically an object so
that's probably what was pissing it off
the most so let's go ahead and see if we
can't add these parameters to all the
places there we did that that's what
happens when you copy and paste and
that's why we need to simplify these
functions because these sorts of things
when we make changes are problematic all
right
yeah and have a button wow what a mess
okay but but it despite not having a
button at least we didn't get that error
we're just getting this whole you know
syntax warning about dat counter but
that's okay right okay so so we made the
buttons but we need there's there's a
few more things we have to do here
clearly I need to probably stop doing
tutorials for the things I'm not
thinking straight
we need to do first of all B dot pack
and then we need to do TK main loop here
and we need to add that to the other
three I believe spots so here we go
again and then scroll up again where
we've got the button pastes again paste
okay try that now see what happens
main middle SMA ten cool submit awesome
blossom middle indicator set to SMA ten
and then what we can do though is we can
go middle indicator EMA ten and then
you'll see that lets you set to you
maintain let's go back down here if
so it looks like it cleared it again
if what does not equal none if middle
indicator is currently none it will do
this else if the what is M SMA it will
add there and then EMA I'm a little
concerned about why it appears to have
cleared middle indicators
all right so I found out the error as
usual it's almost always a typo so what
was happening is our actual variable
name here is the middle indicate tour
but middle indicator is actually
probably better emphasized as middle
indicate orsa because we actually are
under the impression that we're going to
have multiple of them so that that's
where I kind of went wrong logically in
my head and so what ended up happening
was we've got middle indicate tour and
then later on we're doing the middle
indicate towards oh like plural and this
isn't a syntax error or any error really
you're just globally you know some
function or some variable name that's
totally fine but that's what ends up
throwing us out is we've got middle
indicators and we're setting it as
middle indicators that's the problem so
really quickly just find anywhere where
we have middle indicators with multiple
you know plural copy that control H
middle indicators over here middle
indicate or replace all now let's go
ahead and run that and save that counter
but that's fine agree and now we'll go
main middle indicator SMA will pick 10
will see it pop it down here that it
accepted it and then well let's let's
add an EMA of 10 cool and now we see it
now it's added that another indicator to
that list now it's operating as intended
so anyway that's it for this video if
you guys have any questions or comments
sorry about all the errors but that's
part of making a program if you guys
have any questions or comments please
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next